[Music]
in poor babies news or is it in poor
baby's name Oh probably be submitted by
Hendrick a nurse arrested on suspicion
of killing babies oh let's poor baby
Britain's most prolific child killer if
convicted I've never been more upset not
to read about broke babies at least we
caught this [ __ ] sad ass baby is dead
uh yes she has been she has been
arrested corrected I thought all British
people were supposed to be like secret
agents and stuff yeah [ __ ] nice as
Mary Poppins
yeah but Harry Potter's and the dog crew
you know what I heard is I heard that
they only show you the okay [ __ ] in the
movies but in the real life there
they really abuse Harry Potter look in
the books it wasn't real no when Harry
was growing up he was a real guy no I
mean like you don't know that a Daniel
Radcliffe no Harry Potter was a real guy
like they don't show you in the movie
what happens outside of the movie yeah
but in the suit in the book in the
imagination in your mind what are you
speaking what you're saying I'm just
saying I'm gonna translate for Joe he's
saying that in the UK it's a little more
[ __ ] up and a lot of kids are sleeping
under those stairs
right no he's literally talking about
the movie right no there's no book no
he's literally talking about the movie
the part that they didn't show yes yes
the part that they didn't write even in
the yeah or a JK Rowling's mind okay
because he's not real it's that's not
real no it is in the movie - Joel it's
real though they shot a bunch of abuse
scenes in the movie that they don't show
yes even if they did Joe you know those
are fake abuse scenes no it's not it's
real because in the movies real is the
movie only shows you a window of time at
a time so it's like the Bible there's a
huge missing part of Jesus's life from
30 to 40 what the [ __ ] was he doing in
between he was in Japan or something
that's why yeah but people have all
these stories I think you read from 20
to 30 maybe it's 20 to 30 I don't
remember the Bible that well I don't
remember Jesus but there were talks
about teenage Jesus there saying it was
evil as a [ __ ]
they said thanks here come the Paul and
learn how to meditate so that's what I'm
saying is in between the scenes there
was worship going on in that house for
Harry Potter to be that upset to that
abusive ass [ __ ] family I heard
teenage Jesus rebelled against his
parents and that's why he became a Jew
because his parents were like super
Christmas is always a super-duper
Christian Christian till he died hey
while we're destroying history right now
you might as well take it all the way to
the end zone then you could have made
the Mormon or something that's true 18
years huh the Mormon Church has an exist
it's like 10 or 30 years it's like 60
years old or something all right so this
British nurse here uh so her name is
Lucy she's 28 years old allegedly that
[ __ ] so she was arrested for allegedly
murdering allegedly eight newborn babies
and trying to kill six others how does
she do it we don't know yet because this
is just like it's just been reported
that she's been arrested okay so there
still it's an ongoing investigation we
might select it still yeah it's still
alleged and so they're saying that
there's two hospitals that are
investigating her the reason why they
started investigating was because all of
a sudden from me
17 - no sorry from March 2015 to July
2016 there were deaths of 17 and 15
non-fatal collapses which means like
they were about to die with them they
came back so 15 babies were about to die
but then yeah there's a lot of numbers
being thrown here but the point is this
lady's been arrested this is a photo of
her I want to go on an arresting tour
like make you show you how the cops of
different countries are rescues you can
get a taste of that country right along
in every country no I want to arrest it
so like we're not like oh you get
arrested so I'm in LA right we go get on
your [ __ ] knees you [ __ ] and they
[ __ ] slap me against the wall and
they call me a [ __ ] and they may be
like and then they're gonna like plot
the gun put in my mouth maybe that's
1980s la yeah like that's Dirty Harry oh
yeah about that and then you go to like
England and they go please put your
hands behind your back or something so
pleasant British people cut you out it
sound so nice yeah
then you go to Thailand or something and
then it's like a female cop but then you
feel like a dick between your butt
cheeks and then go to like all the
different countries and you just feel
the way it is to get arrest in all
different countries I'd be super down
with them arrest yeah what you guys want
to do it yeah why I'm see what the
police cultures like she's killing them
did they say they didn't say yeah they
didn't say so how could they even like
what's their proof that it's her what is
she just a clumsy ass [ __ ] and every
time she's just [ __ ] up all this [ __ ]
and that's why the baby
drop it babies and [ __ ] I am just very
clumsy I can't deny no stop I want to
hear it's like with the TV's on and like
your parents are making noise or like
the people around you and I'm like I'm
trying to hear what's going on the TV's
my whole childhood Nicky let her talk
[Laughter]
yeah so the police themselves haven't
identified her but she was identified by
like friends and family because
apparently like they went they went to
her home they put up like blue tarp near
her house and stuff and they were
searching like all these cops were there
they were searching over there too so
they were the neighbors were being the
neighbors were being interviewed and
every single person that has been
interviewed has all said the same thing
which was she was a super kind-hearted
person like she worked so hard to be a
nurse she dedicated herself to her job
don't mean us that's what like what's
that what's the evidence against her
it's alleged they can't tell us yet the
evidence for her is weak to pass what is
it is it just that she was on shift when
all the babies died and so they're like
giving us anything because I'm pretty
sure whatever it is it's like oh this is
a weird occurrence every time that [ __ ]
is on shift a baby dies or something
like that and they investigate her and
then they gotta [ __ ] tell the Popo
and and do all this [ __ ] but they're
like exposing patients have her in all
kinds of stuff like that's it's got to
be something wouldn't you tell you the
detail because uh while he's in America
until after the case yeah so we tell you
why I was trying to help her cause she
doesn't have the information so I'm just
trying to make up some [ __ ] pretty
sure there's surveillance footage of
this lady just what the baby like [ __ ]
disgusting image as of this moment I
don't have any information they haven't
released any like why this is the why
they suspect her so maybe by the time
these people are watching the video
there might be more information but as
of right now I do not because they at
least they're like well she was
poisoning she probably tweeted a baby
joke and then they arrived we protect
all criminals she [ __ ] shook the [ __ ]
out of them no there's a crazy
unexplained mortality rate spike in the
hospital shooters
I don't know if it was doing her [ __ ] it
could be like those nurses that
administer like shitty poison things -
yeah they're very sick [ __ ] - no babies
in the US and that's what she was doing
make she was because like she had like
this like I don't know this like
superhero like she wanted to be a
superhero so she was like trying to save
these babies like she would make them
sick like munchausen syndrome is that
what it's called me expert it's where
they make their kids sick so that they
have to take care of them so the kid
like needs to lady the mom with the
little girl that she like purposely made
her sick she would like shave her head
and she was asking for donations and the
make-a-wish Foundation all that whole do
something and that little girl killed
her
what do you call it when it's the kid
purposely being sick because I did that
[ __ ] I'll kill my mom take time off work
and I'm [ __ ] feel pampered again
that's just being a kid that's called
all kids that called son all kids are
neglected I didn't do that
I shut up I didn't want my mom around
damn
and he raps about it what mom syndrome
oh poor Eminem man he would make if she
would make him take pills and stuff and
that's how I got addicted to coke oh no
baby you sick or let me take care of you
mm-hm
I gotta take time off work to take care
my behavior yeah I did try searching I
tried doing my research the best I could
and I could not find any information I
didn't try hard enough
dude we're gonna look at the comments in
the first the first comment is gonna
have like a links at all the [ __ ] I know
why are you only looking at the comments
that [ __ ] you know you never said thank
you guys for you always calling me so
pretty and I'm so smart this is where I
get my shirt comments on our videos cuz
they're really mean so but they come to
like my personal stuff and that's when I
see it and you just advertised to where
they can all other people who come to
your personal stuff I go follow me on
Instagram there you go call the trolls
there you go
and then I'll block you you really mean
but let's take this moment to balance it
out because there's also a lot of dough
man's got a [ __ ] that they deserve
the attention really because they're
they're really cool especially when you
don't need to say anything and they're
doing all the correcting for you that's
the cool [ __ ]
save me from commenting you're super
sweet a lot of you guys are so sweet you
always have my back thank you so much I
love you but honestly I don't have
information on this story but the point
is it's crazy because this lady since
she's so young - and she's been accused
accused of killing so many babies so is
it gonna be like life in UK prison I
don't know yet oh I feel like they would
never at least even just her name if she
had her picture her name all the stuff
she's gotta be the police never named
her walk wherever name cuz that's just
bad like they're gonna get sued like
[ __ ] crazy if she's over there
she hasn't sure you know that was soo
happy over there well they're not too
happy but they can ene yeah they can - I
don't know I've ever heard of it
happening I don't know I don't know [ __ ]
about the laws over there well I mean I
think I don't know they can't get to cuz
she did get arrested for this it's just
that the police themselves haven't named
her it's just people around that said
like oh it's her and then obviously
since you don't arrest you they don't
mean to hold you for like what is the
police there have really tall hats that
look really funny and cute it's so
[ __ ] cheap and it looks like Hot Dog
on a Stick little [ __ ] batons that
are this big yeah see that's how you to
catch me I have a car that's the real
thing we should be talking about is why
is it that our police looks so
militarized and scary and all the other
countries are the cutest cops so [ __ ]
cute and then they're crazy if you're so
cute have you seen the Japanese cop cars
- they look like little minivan yeah
thank you
we go we
yes and they peddle drive them they
don't even have been we have yeah did
you have an engine yeah they look like
Hall monitors and [ __ ] and they have
like strobe light little sirens whoo man
that's what I want what a cute cop I
don't want to get anxiety attacks when I
get pulled over you know I get anxiety
attacks just by seeing it behind me oh
yeah who pulls over by the way there's
like bike cops in Venice Beach who pulls
over for that [ __ ] do they force upon
your eyes all that bicycle bicycle we
are when I lived in Hollywood there were
horse cops and they would they would
give homeless people tickets and they
were like that was their ruling they
would ride around Hollywood yeah there
is horse cops but the bicycle cops they
don't pull over people what they do is
[ __ ] crazy I saw this in Santa Monica
one time dude was like some guy walking
around and then the bike cop just came
up and then jumped off and [ __ ]
tackled his ass and his other group guy
came and then [ __ ] cuffed them yeah
was it a movie it was real life it was
real life was it the parts of the movie
they cut out
[Music]